want to play a game Netflix's Smash Hit
squid game is coming back with a
vengeance in 2024 and the streaming
company's quick teaser gives us just
enough to speculate on squid game took
Netflix by storm in 2021 with the South
Korean hit becoming the streaming
services most watched original series at
the time since then fans have been
treated to a reality TV spin-off called
squid game The Challenge as they wait
for the main show to return the good
news however is that the wait is almost
over as Netflix has released a
tantalizing teaser for squid Game season
2 the clip picks up from where the
season 1 finale left off as guih hun
walks through an airport and he's out
for revenge against the squid games
Founders the winner of the titular
deadly competition speaks with one of
the game's mysterious organizers on the
phone who tells guihan that he'll regret
the decision to disobey him however
guihan isn't intimidated by the threat
as he promises to find his enemy and end
the squid game once and for all squid
Game season 2 looks set to be an
action-packed and bloody Affair that
will dig deeper into the lore of this
universe IE with that in mind let's
anticipate what we can expect from the
next installment of Netflix's
International hit squid Game season 1
ends with s giian being financially well
off but feeling more unfulfilled than
ever he learns that his old friend
contestant 001 is still alive even
though he's terminally ill and not the
humble good man he thought he was it
turns out that the old man is one of the
masterminds behind the squid game as he
and his rich friends created it as a
means of entertainment naturally this
upsets giih hun and he isn't willing to
stand for it you put us through all of
that so you can have fun the season 2
teaser confirms that guihan will be out
to take down the creators of the deadly
game and put a stop to their barbarity
sporting a new red hairo and a desire to
end the corruption guihan has gone from
being a down on his luck every man to a
vengeful Warrior but is he strong enough
to stop this entire operation on his own
only time will tell while speaking to
The Hollywood Reporter Creator hang dang
yuk said the next installment will also
explore the backstory of the man who
recruits guihan for the squid game in
season 1 additionally he detailed plans
to dig into the story of the frontman
and gun's family history it remains to
be seen what's in store for viewers but
at least they won't have long to wait
squid Game season 2 will be released
sometime this
year